early start
okay great well welcome everyone
it's a great pleasure to have Robert
twang here he's
um he's a PhD student at Caltech and
already at this stage he's done a lot of
exciting work on
um uh efficiently learning uh
uh you know Quantum systems making
predictions about them he has this work
on classical Shadows which he's already
spoken about here so it's it's pretty uh
remarkable that already at this stage
he's um he's one of the few people who
is speaking more than once at the
quantum colloquium so today he'll tell
us about very recent work on
um on learning to predict arbitrary
Quantum processes so looking forward to
it Robert
yeah thank you so much for the
introduction uh my name is Robert and
today I'll be talking about learning to
predict arbitrary Quantum processes this
is a John work within and John presco
so very recently we have seen a lot of
progress in understanding how to
efficiently learn and predict Quantum
States in particular through the
development in Shadow tomography
classical Shadows Etc and in today's
talk I will be focusing on understanding
if it's possible to develop efficient
learning algorithms for predicting
Quantum circuits or even more generally
Quantum processes
so understanding such a question is
important and could potentially lead to
many advances in different fields for
example if we can efficiently predict
how chemicals would interact with one
another then it could potentially be to
design a better Catalyst or drugs it
could also potentially gain allow us to
gain new insights into exotic content
many body Dynamics or can help us
Benchmark Quantum devices and understand
how to improve them
in today's talk
um the setting that I'm going to work
with is the following so essentially the
basic problem is to train a machine
learning algorithm so that it can learn
to predict the following function given
by Fe so this function takes in two
objects the first is an input Quantum
State and the second is an observable
and the unknown part of the problem is
there exist this unknown Quantum process
represented by a cptp map e and the goal
of the ml algorithm is to learn about
this unknown process e so that given
some input State roll it can predict
what's the property under this
observable o for the
for the output state so as one can see
this includes any function that's
computable by a quantum computer and
furthermore if we don't place any
restriction on the CPTV map e for
example this could potentially be an
exponentially deep Quantum circuit then
this might also require an exponential
time for quantum computer to efficiently
learn and to efficiently compute such a
function
in particular there are this kind of
problem arises in various different
settings
um the first is say we wanted to predict
outcomes of a physical experiment say
for example the
initial State
um is given by say some classical
description that describe the initial
configuration of certain Quantum system
and say that's represented by row
and this unknown cptp map e is
essentially the physical process that
happened in the experiment and finally
um what the scientists mentioned at the
end is this observable and the goal is
to be able to predict what if we
configure certain different chemical or
certain different configurations what's
the corresponding output of the physical
experiments and the second example
considers a setting that arises in
training Quantum neural networks so
quality networks are essentially just a
parametrized Quantum circuit so you have
a unitary that's parametrized and you
can think of that as an unknown cptb map
and in this case usually what people
consider is there are some classical
Vector X
what people would do is then one would
encode that into a Quantum State through
some fixed encoding or perhaps some
trained encoding and then there's going
to be
the quantum neural network that would
evolve the state role and then at the
end we will measure some single fixed
observable so say some fixed local
observable like ZZ correlation in at the
output State and people try to train
such a neural network to do different
kind of tasks that's also encompassed by
this setting and the third example also
arrives in the literature but mostly
done in a more heuristic fashion where
the goal is to train a machine learning
algorithm to speed up Quantum Dynamics
so in this case the cvtb map e is
actually known and it's a it's a Quantum
Dynamics maybe some unitary that we will
try to compress and speed up and the
goal is to train an ml model such that
hopefully the ml model could find some
more efficient way to essentially
predict what's what if you feed in this
role and what's the corresponding
observable oh that one measure so these
are the three examples that follows this
setting and this is going to be the main
sort of problem we're going to look at
more precisely the goal is the following
so suppose we're given some 10 cubic
cptp map e that represents a very highly
complex Quantum process so it could
potentially have say exponential
complexity in it
and the goal is to perform some
experiments on this complex Quantum
process to generate some classical data
set about the process process this using
classical computer and after that create
a learned model so that given some new
input States one could utilize this
learned model to predict properties of
the output state so that's going to be
the main goal of today's stock
and I'm going to separate the talk into
the following three parts the first I
will talk about a classical version of
the problem then I will look at a
restricted version and finally the last
part I would generalize it to tackle the
original content problem that we that we
just described so as I started let's
look at a classical version of this
content problem
so this is actually a well studied
problem and here instead of having a
Quantum process we just have say some
unknown classical Boolean circuit C that
maps unbits to n Bits so now the input
is not a Quantum State anymore it's just
um a bit string X and let's say we also
to make the problem easier we focus on a
fixed property so we just wanted to
predict a single output bit of the
Boolean circuit so let's say it's the
first output bit so now we can write out
the relationship between the input X and
the output
um as the as this function have C of X
and in a more Quantum terminology that
would be you prepare some basis State X
evolve under this Boolean circuit C
which gives rise to another basis State
and now you take the trace with Z1 that
will give you a number that's either one
or negative one because C of X is a is a
basis state
so this problem has been studied
um substantially in the classical
learning theory literature
um and it's well known that this is very
hard
um so first let's look at the worst case
situation so suppose that we want to
learn a model hfx such that
um hfx and fcfx differs by less than 0.5
for all the input X
and now the main problem here is that
this function of C is actually a an
unstructured function so it it can take
any X into any value negative plus or
negative one so one way to think about
this is this is just an exponentially
long Vector with two to the N different
entries and there's no structure to it
so if you wanted to learn such a
function you have to query fcfx for all
input X and as a result it will give
rise to a query complexity that grows
exponentially in system size
but that's only for worst case actually
even if you consider the average case
that is you wanted to learn a model hfx
such that when you have a randomly
sample X from say the uniform
distribution over this m-bit strings if
you wanted to have this average case
prediction error that's just last and
say 0.5 which is a pretty big number
um then one can easily show that we
still need to query fcfx for at least
half of all the input bit string X the
reason is because if you didn't query
some part of some part of the input all
you can do the actually the best you can
do is just predict zero because that
gives you a prediction error of one but
then if you only query it for less than
half of the input then your prediction
error is going to be greater than 0.5
and as a result you have to query at
least half of it and since there's an
exponential number of them use Capital
query 0.5 times 2 to the end so that
still gives rise to a query complexity
that scales exponentially
um in system size
so so one could really see that if you
don't impose anything about the
classical circuit it's a very hard
problem the query complexity grows
exponentially in both worst case and
average case and it's well known that
this is the case
and now
um very recently people have also shown
that if we restrict ourselves to say
shallow classical circuit then the
problem is still computationally hard
um this is no longer a query
um inefficient but assuming that lwe is
hard for quantum computer to solve then
one could prove that um
even achieving a small constant average
prediction error is computationally hard
even on quantum computers and this is
true even when you restrict the
Constable Boolean circuit to be constant
times
um particular the more precise
statements is constant depth Boolean
circuit with majority gain that is
circuits in this class known as tc0 this
is still hard
as one could see from just a review of
these well-known results in classical
learning theory this problem is indeed
very challenging
um when you just focus on the classical
analog of it that is
when you look at this problem where the
input is just plus and minus and the
circuit is a classical Boolean circuit
this is exponentially hard problem to
solve
and now what we would like to look at is
sort of a Quantum analog of this which
also forms a restricted version of what
we're going to talk about at the end
so in this case we replace the classical
Circuit by a Quantum process it's also
an arbitrarily High complexity process
and we also only focus on predicting the
excitation value for the first qubit the
Z1
but now instead of having input states
that are just product uh that are just
like
basis States like this bit strings we
focus on input states that are tensor
product of single qubit pure States so
so this is just this product State and
now we would like to understand if this
problem is actually harder than the
original classical problem
particularly similar to how we can
Define this function FC which is also
equivalent to having this exponentially
long Vector we can also Define an
Associated object which is this
observable oh
this observable is essentially the
Heisenberg evolution of this Z1 under
this unknown Quantum process so this
observable o would also be an unknown
object it's an unknown highly complex
observable and for the classical problem
that we just look at here
this observable would be diagonal and
the diagonal of that observable would
just be this exponentially long Vector
um that we just talked about but now
this can potentially have off-diagonal
elements
um so so it can it's a more expressive
model and now the goal that we want to
understand is
is it possible that we can efficiently
learn about this observable oh such that
given some product States we can predict
the expectation value efficiently
so what we're going to do is we're going
to look at this data set it's a very
simple data set essentially we just
prepare some random products today so
like sampling random examples evolving
under this process and then measure at
the first qubit and which is equivalent
to Preparing around the product State
and measuring this observable oh
so now what you get is you're going to
get this classical data set say we do
this for capital in different times now
we would have capital in different
random product states with their
Associated value yl so yl is going to be
a random variable that's either plus 1
or negative one because when you measure
it it just gives you plus or negative
one but its expectation value would be
equal to the desired quantity that is
the expectation value of O
um in this random product State PSI l
so now the prediction tasks as follows
we're given this classical data set
about this unknown highly complex
observable oh and the goal is to learn
from this data set so that given a new
state here we're just going to focus on
product State given a new product State
we can predict the expectation value
accurately now it's like kind of a Duo
of the classical Shadow problem where
you're in Costco Shadow you try to learn
about States but now this is like
essentially learning about this
observable o which is unknown and this
observable o is as I said it's the
Heisenberg evolution of Z1 under the
unknown Quantum process
and one could also map it back to the
classical problem so in the classical
problem this observable o would be a
diagonal matrix and all of these states
PSI would be restricted to tensor
product of 0 and 1
um bits instead of more generally this
kind of piercing
so now using this
relation between
the using this reduction one can easily
show the worst case hardness for this
problem to say if we want to learn a
model at job site such that given any
product State PSI You can predict the
expectation value of o on this product
State up to a constant error say 0.5 one
can easily show that this problem is at
least as hard as a classical problem so
all the hardness translate into this
here so you get like query complexity
for this has to scale at least
exponentially
um in in system size so in the worst
case this this problem is even harder
however
um it's not entirely clear what happens
when you consider the average case
um so in particular suppose we would
like to learn a model such that for a
random product State we can we can
predict the excitation value of O
accurately up to some constant
um previously we've seen that for the
classical problem this is still
exponentially hard you'd still need like
2 to the N minus one query in order to
in order to solve this problem but
what's interesting here is that for this
Quantum analog the the this problem is
no longer hard in particular the
training set size can be made very small
and the computational time could also be
made into quasi-polynomial
and that's essentially what we're going
to talk about throughout this talk like
why is this the case and what's the
underlying techniques for establishing
this result saying that in order to
predict an arbitrarily complex
observable
we can do it efficiently
so the main question or yeah are we went
to the answer questions or
um
Iz do you have a preference on can we no
no please please go ahead one yeah go
ahead yeah I just want to make sure I
understood like sort of like the right
analogy between the quantum problem and
the classical problem because what I had
in my mind would be like okay
um the quantum State Row the analog
should be like a probability
distribution and like the observable the
analog should be like a random variable
or a function from the the domain of the
distribution to the reals and I guess
like the quantum process script e would
be like a stochastic Matrix so like this
was a little bit like the the analog I
was expecting but it didn't seem to
quite match onto the slides that you
like do I have a
so
I guess you're saying like um here maybe
we should consider more generally not
just classical circuit but say a
stochastic classical circuit I think
that that could make sense but I mean
that that makes the problem harder right
I guess like for example like what is
like uh the analog of row here like I
expected it to be a probability
distribution
oh yeah but here this is um that's in in
this specific restriction we're just
focusing on pure state so
I guess it's uh so like it's a it's a
probability distribution with one
outcome I see yeah so so I I would
imagine that the corresponding analog of
pure stage should be the basis States in
classical world so that's how I make the
analogy um I guess so I guess both of
you apply like okay
I guess maybe then in that case like the
outcome of the circuit is like the
probability distribution
right that's true
okay well let me not take too much time
I think I think I understand what's
going on okay okay yeah so here we're
just focusing on on on pure State
instead of like uh like like mixtape I
guess if it's mixtape then definitely
that should also be a distribution over
input rather than
but yes but I agree
um there are some relation
um
I mean you'll get like a mixtape when
you put it through script e right
um yeah but that's that's most generally
but you can also have this e to be a uh
like a
a unitary right so then you still can
appear stain
okay so so go going back next um so
essentially the the main difference
between the two setting is actually
whether there exists low weight
approximation so lower approximation is
just the following say we write out the
observable as the Nepali basis which is
essentially a form of Fourier transform
and now we just truncate all the highway
probably that is this absolute value of
P just consider how many non-identity
components is in the Pali and we only
retain ones that have non-identity
that's less than equal to K so now we
have this low weight observable L of
now
what we have for the quantum setting is
the following Lemma essentially when you
have on average some random pure product
state is aside then the expectation
value of O is actually going to be close
to the expectation value of oh low and
it actually would Decay exponentially if
you make the low weight the weight
higher and higher
so intuitively one could think about it
as following that's that means that for
most of the product State psiope PSI
would be approximately equal to psi o
lobe sign essentially we can use this
low weight approximation as a good
surrogate for the original observable
and this is where the the two setting
actually depart is that this low wave
approximation doesn't hold in the
classical version of the problem that is
when you average over just basis States
you you don't get this decay in one over
three to the K so in the classical
setting the observable is diagonal and
all of these expectation values are over
basis States in that kind of situation
um
you you even if you take K to be very
large
um there's not necessarily going to be
any sort of Decay and that's when the
quantum and the classical setting
departs and that's why this Quantum
problem becomes easier than the
classical problem and one way that I
think about this which I think is going
to get closer to what Ryan was asking
was in the classical setting these
classical inputs they're all perfectly
distinguishable so you can have a
measurement that can perfectly
distinguish it so in this case the the
the function you're trying to learn can
be highly sensitive to what your input
is basically just changing a bit can
result in completely different results
and so that's why when you learn about
some of the classical inputs you don't
learn about anything about for the other
part of the classical inputs on the
other hand when you have this like pure
Quantum States input they are no longer
perfectly distinguishable from one
another they have a lot of overlap for
example zero stage and plus states have
a lot of overlap so when you learn
something about zero State you actually
can infer about things on the plus State
and because these random products they
have so much overlap with one another
locally
um they actually like learning about
some allows you to infer about other and
that's why the learning problem can
become much easier another way to think
about this is because they are not
perfectly distinguishable you cannot
create a function so that it varies very
dramatically when you move in this
Quantum like you move in this Quantum
product State space so
that smoothness and the lack of
sensitivity essentially says that when
you have a random product State like for
most of the random product most of the
product State
um you're not going to see the high
frequency component of the original
observable and that's why you can do low
wave approximation to the original
observable and still
um get good prediction so so it is this
kind of settings about the quantumness
of the input state that actually makes
this low weight approximation possible
so using this very simple idea one can
then say oh now what the ml model should
do is they should just learn the low
weight approximation you should learn
the low end observable for some small K
and we know that using the low weight
approximation Lemma
um it will give similar prediction as
the original observable in the average
case in particular learning this low
width observable is possible using the
following identity on Fourier
transformation so in particular all of
these poly coefficient Alpha p in this
lower observable can be reconstructed
using this uh this this estimation
essentially you take the output State
output yl in the classical data set
multiply it by the side l p player
for some low weight p and average over
it and properly rescale it and then you
would get the alpha P coefficient
so so by doing but but this is only
going to be accurate in expectation
value
um in in practice there's going to be
statistical fluctuation in in this
reconstruction
um so
we have to control the statistical error
in order to understand how many how much
data is actually required in order to
learn a good approximation to this low
weight observo oh though
would you have a similar effect
classically if like instead of like
querying just like one full string of
pluses and minuses you've queried like
half the bits or plus or minus one
random and half of them are like stars
to get like the average over like
filling in of the Stars
so what do you mean stars like instead
of like requesting like what is the
function on like this all you know
string of bits plus or minus one like
it's kind of like the Eraser model like
you put like a question mark in for like
one third of the bits and you get back
the average over always of filling in
those question marks
yeah it will become also easy right I
think uh we become like more analogous
Maybe
that's that's true that's true because
it yeah I think like for example if you
just consider zero one versus plus minus
like that's your Quantum input then in
that case the plus minus um becomes more
like the like the star that you're
mentioning right so in that case
um if the if the function is not
yeah if the function is just diagonal
then that will become the start
um that that you're mentioning and I
think in that case that you would also
get the low weight approximations I
think that's that's definitely or maybe
if you allow for sorry maybe also if you
allow for random distributions in the
classical case product distribution for
example
so you I guess you're saying like um
laughs
you're saying like say you have this
product State and now you just take the
diagonal of it then then
yeah so I'm just trying to understand
your intuition that the classical case
is sharp where the quantum case is
smooth right and you cannot so if you if
your input in the classical case is just
like a product state of
a distribution of strings but the
distribution is simple it's a product
state of of single bits distribution
then it also is smooth it is no longer
uh so sharp and you can and you cannot
distinguish so much between different
distributions and different distribution
maybe will give you different more
information about I mean so would it be
the same in that case I mean with the
classical case be easier I think so like
if you if you try to smooth out your
input kind of like putting in stars or
making it like um like a smooth
distribution that would also enable
something like a low weight
approximation I think okay and that
would also make the problem easier
um right one thing that's here okay so
so there are two situations first is you
can pick an observable which is just
diagonal now the quantum input is
essentially going to be smoothing things
out
um in that space But one might ask like
maybe what if you pick some other
observable
um that are in the quantum space Could
you actually still make it sensitive but
essentially the answer is no you can you
cannot make it sensitive because the
because the quantum State inputs are
just not not orthogonal to one another
and that that causes these kind of
overlaps which are similar to like you
just kind of smooth out the input of the
classical things that would also make
the complexity uh much slower so I think
thank you
yeah so now um the question becomes how
large should the data size and be
um in order for us to learn a good
approximation to this low width
observable and essentially what we will
show next is if you wanted to learn it
up to a constant relative error then we
actually only need a number of training
data that's logarithmically in system
size in order to answer this question we
would have to uh do a very big detour
and talk about something completely
different
um so so I'm going to talk about a
different task on optimizing Quantum
hamiltonians and using the guarantee of
an optimization algorithm I'm going to
go back and and resolve the question
about how much data is required to learn
this low degree approximation
so the task is very simple we're given
some uncubed K Local hamiltonian H which
is the sum of poly operator that have
Mo's um K non-identity the goal is to
find some state that tries to maximize
or minimizes the energy so you might not
find the optimum state but you might
find some good enough state that have
either higher value of energy or lower
value of that energy
in particular we want to have a
guarantee on this PSI H PSI based on the
description of the hamiltonian edge so
there are several works that focuses on
Guarantee of this energy based on the
optimum value but there are also several
works that focus on the guarantee based
on say the poly coefficient Alpha P so
so so for this part of talk we're going
to be closer to the second one the
letter which is we wanted to have a
guarantee that depends on the structure
of the hamiltonian and what this poly
coefficient Alpha PR
in particular
we have to first Define a notion called
the expansion property so given a
hamiltonian h we say it has an expansion
coefficient CE and an expansion
Dimension d e if for every size d e
region R the number of poly observable P
that have non-zero coefficient and
furthermore it's either being fully
covered by the region r or fully covers
the region r that is these two
conditions the number of these poly
operator is utmost CE so just to give
some example say we focus on a size 2
region consisting of these two qubits
and here are just some examples of poly
string such that it would count into
into these the set that follows this so
first is that the domain of P which is
the qubits that P axon complete matches
so like this ZZ term or it fully covers
this so like z x x y z term or it's
being fully covered by R so that's
corresponds to say for example this x
term so essentially we just try to count
how many CE
um CE is more of a
sort of a simpler parameter like when
you change it it doesn't really affect
too much but the dimension really
um comes into play greatly so Dimension
One and dimension two will be very
different and would also be very
different from Dimension three and so on
particular here are some example suppose
that you have a geometrical local
hamiltonian on some finite dimensional
Grid in that case one could show that D
E equals to one and C is just a constant
because for every qubit which is a size
1 region the number of poly operator
that acts on it would just be a constant
so C is one the second example we say we
have a general K local hamiltonian so
you have all possible K body interaction
in that case one could select d e to be
equal to K so now for every K region
there's only going to be at most four to
the K different
um
poly strings that acts on it because
it's a k-lo cometonian it's a C equals
to 14 okay
and the final example is when we look at
a degree D two body hematism so that
means in the hamiltonians there are only
um two body interactions and for each
qubit it's only going to be involved in
um interactions with the other qubits in
the system so in that case one could
also show that d e would be equal to one
and the CE would be equal to 16 D so
that's just an output I hope this gives
a sort of a picture about how this de
scales usually for geometrically local
things these scales it's just one but
when you have these more and more
non-local hamiltonians then these start
to grow gradually
and the main theorem that we show is the
following so suppose we have a
hamptonian that has expansion
coefficients CE and dimension d e
then if we Define this this r value
which is
between 1 and 2 so say if D equals to
one this r value is just equal to one
but when D when d e becomes larger and
larger this r value would also grow and
becomes closer to two
now given this three parameters c e d
and r we haven't we can write down an
efficient algorithm that either finds a
maximizing product state with an energy
PSI H PSI greater than equal to the
average the energy of the random state
plus this Advantage term so it's going
to be better than a random state by this
amount and the most important part of it
is this
our Norm on the alpha P coefficient
so we can see that if D equals to 1 r
equal to one so you get the one Norm
otherwise you get something like 1.5
Norm or 1.6 norm and so on and
we call that when the norm becomes like
one Norm is much larger than two Norm so
if you can get a one Norm advantage that
would be much better than getting a two
Norm advantage and then there's also
some dependence on Ce that was much
milder it's c e to the one over two d e
and there's also going to be an
exponential dependence on the locality
of the hamiltonian so usually we should
consider K to be small which is indeed
the case in our previous learning theory
um kind of Investigation
so the algorithm either finds such a
maximizing product state or it finds a
minimizing product state with a very
similar guarantee but just replacing
this plus with minus and then with this
greater than equal to by less than equal
to so because now we want the state to
be have lower energy and as low as
possible
so that's the main theorem and one could
also compare it with some of the
previous results and essentially the
main Improvement I would say comes from
this portion this portion about just
dependence on the r Norm previously
there are results that depends on say
Alpha P to the four divided by the
maximum of some of these Alpha p and so
on so so in various situations this
result is going to give asymptotically
better result in particular we actually
need the improve thing in order to
establish some of our learning theoretic
um applications
so now what I would like to briefly do
is to just showcase what this algorithm
looks like because I think there are
some interesting aspects to it
um the first step is pretty standard
um we just consider breaking up the
hamiltonian into different slices so you
have the one body slice two body slice
three body and so on then we just select
a slice with the largest value of these
Alpha coefficients so we
restricted and then focused on a
hamiltonian that only has kabadi poly
string now what we would do is we would
create K replicas for the system so for
Simplicity let's say k equal to three so
now we would have this
Unk qubit system so K replicas of the
n-cubus system and for the first K minus
two replicas we're just going to select
random products then
and then we're going to optimize for the
final replica
and the way we do the optimization is
the following we take the hamiltonian
and then we lift it to this NK qubit
system and we lifted using what we call
polarization that is it's just a
a linear operation that's been defined
on the poly operator and then we just
linearly extend it to the space of
hamiltonians
so to give an example say we wanted to
construct the polarization of a poly
string P equal to Z x y i i then in this
case what we would do is we would
consider the average of the following
six different Unk qubit poly string so
the first one is this zxy and this one
this one this one and this one and this
one so so there's only six because we
focus on k equal to 3 but essentially
the number of things we average over
would be K factorial
so the purpose of this polarization is
that it breaks apart the interaction
um kind of structure in particular you
can see that for this first qubit of of
the final replica it's only going to be
involved in interactions that contains
one qubit in replica two and one qubit
in replica one so for example for in
this part it would only involve
um these two interactions so as one can
see there's not going to be any
interaction between different qubits in
this final replica meaning that we can
just optimize for each of the qubit in
the final replica individually so we're
just going to do an exact optimization
to find the best product state that
optimizes the energy of this
polarization of edge and say we found
some things like this what we're going
to then do is we're going to essentially
just Mash together all of these black
Vector individually
using a random weighted sum
to get some Direction
and now after doing that this will form
a high dimensional direction that we're
going to optimize over that is we're
going to look into this direction and
try to optimize for the trace of H times
the on the products thing try to
optimize for the energy we're just going
to do a Brute Force 1D optimization
consider all possible grids and then
just pick the one with the best value
and with the proper set of
um analysis we can establish this
theorem and the best part about this is
this nice Norm regarding the alpha p
so why do we want to create such a
improved authorization algorithm is that
this allows us a way to prove a
generalized version of a Content Bond
and plus CL inequality
and this inequality States the following
it says that suppose you're given an
arbitrary given an observable o that can
be written as the weighted sum of poly
strings with weight up to K with an
expansion coefficient CE and a dimension
d e then we can prove that the spectral
Norm of O will upper bound some constant
times the r Norm of these Alpha
coefficient
so why do we want such a thing so
essentially in many practical situations
we actually we understand what's the
Spectrum number oh basically that just
means when we measure certain things how
big the deviation is going to take say
in many cases we can normalize this so
now the observable is always takes
values between negative one and one so
in that case the spectral Norm of O
would just be one and now what this
theorem essentially says is when you
have this one on the left hand side you
can essentially use it to Upward Bound
um the r Norm of the
Pali the Fourier coefficient these poly
coefficient particular R is going to be
some value between 1 and 2. and that's
going to be a very important part
and the proof of this theorem is very
straightforward based on the guarantee
for this optimization algorithm which is
take the guarantee and we just note that
the Spectrum mfo upper bounds the energy
when you think of O as the hamiltonian
the energy of
um of the state that's being generated
by the algorithm and then we just take
essentially this theorem shown here with
some massaging and now we would get this
Norm inequality
okay so this this is a little bit
technical but let me try to sort of say
a few words about why this inequality is
useful in different situations so first
let's focus on this observo oh being a
sum of geometrically local terms in that
situation we have already shown that D E
equals to 1 and C is just a constant and
by plugging everything into this button
plus here generalized bonding plus here
inequality we can see that the one Norm
of the alpha P would be upper bounded by
the constant times the spectrum of L so
as we've talked about before if the
spectral Norm of O is just a constant
say one then we suddenly get a upper
bound saying that the one Norm of alpha
P would be upper bounded by a constant
and what that actually means is the
following so
we call that in literature like
compressed sensing when there's some
unknown Vector so recall that this o is
like the thing that's unknown when we
whenever we have some unknown object
like I don't know Vector that is sparse
then we can learn it very efficiently
just like a logarithmic in the dimension
we can learn it
and particularly one could also
generalize those results to one Norm
bound so if you have a good one arm
bound that also means that you sell for
PR approximately sparse and hence you
can also learn it very very efficiently
so that's that's how this is going to
come into play later in the stock
and another example which is now
becoming closer and closer to this low
weight observable that we talked about
say this observable is just a general
sum of K local terms then we have
Dimension D E equals to K and the c e
would be 4 to the k
not in this situation we can also plug
it back in and what we get is this
inequality saying that the
R Norm where R equals to 2K over K plus
1 the r Norm of this Alpha Vector is
going to be upper bounded by
some value that scales exponentially in
K times the spectrum of one and again
similar to before since this 2K over K
plus 1 is something between 1 and 2. it
also implies the form of approximate
sparsity meaning that this Alpha thinks
it's going to have a large a large
number of coefficients that are very
close to zero and setting them to zero
is not going to change it too much
and this inequality is a direct Quantum
analog of the bottom block scale
inequality which is uh which is a result
that holds for um
yeah which is a result regarding
multilinear uh pulling outputs
so now we can after getting these two
inequalities we can go back to the
original talk I'm learning to predict
arbitrary Quantum processes
so recall that the quantum problem is we
have some random product State and the
goal is to be able to predict the
expectation value of Z1 for the output
state
and the basic idea we have done I've
obtained so far is that we wanted to
learn the low weight approximation of
this highly complex unknown observable
and the question we are addressing is
how large should the data size NB so
that we can efficiently learn this low
weight observable
and now using this barnabasion
inequality we because it's approximately
sparse
um we can essentially learn it very
efficiently very similar to literature
and compressed sensing in particular the
use of bound and plus yield inequalities
for learning classical function was also
exploited in a recent work
um that are that is published this year
so now the essential algorithm is the
following
what we essentially do is we just go
through all these different low wave
poly string we use the Fourier
transformation
identity to get an estimate for these
Alpha P coefficient and then because
it's approximately sparse so if we found
that this Alpha hat p is small quite
close to zero then we just set it to
zero and now the Learned observable is
just a way to sound I mean way to buy
this estimated Alpha P hat
so now one can get some rigorous
guarantee for for for this task for
example if we consider a small constant
Epsilon then given the training set size
capital N that scales logarithmically in
system size we can ensure that the
prediction error of predicting the low
weight observable using this low-weight
estimated observable o hat low will be
upper bounded by this small constant
meaning that if you wanted to get a
small relative error
a training set size of login is enough
and now recall that
this oh low is close to the original
observable oh so but it would incur an
additional component Epsilon coming from
the low weight approximation but
essentially
using triangle equality you can easily
get this result saying that for any
small constant Epsilon and Epsilon Prime
given as training set size that's very
small the prediction error can be upper
bounded by Epsilon plus Epsilon Prime
Times the spectral Norm of oh low
so now if we also look at the scaling
with respect to Epsilon and Epson Prime
essentially one could show that the
training set side has to grow quasi
polynomially in whatever Epsilon and one
over Epsilon Prime but the full scaling
is essentially log n times this quasi
polynomial factor and now we can get the
prediction error to to arbitrary small
things that scales with Epsilon and
Epsilon Prime
so so as we have seen the original
problem the classical problem where the
input stream can really be just complete
bit string rather than like distribution
or some with star in it that that
problem is exponentially hard on the
other hand when we focus on the quantum
problem where it's just a product State
because these product States they they
they're not while they're pure they're
not like mixture of distribution they're
they're still incompatible to one
another so in this case low degree
approximation works and when low
approximation works one can combine with
these techniques to show that one can
learn it very efficiently and also the
the computational time with scale
quasi-polynomial in the system size n
but that only resolves a restricted
version of this problem where we focus
on having product State and we focus on
only predicting
um a single poly
observable Z1 on the output string now
we would like to generalize it to the
original problem
so we called that the original goal was
to actually learn this Quantum process
so that for General input State we can
predict various properties after Alpha
State not just D1 and not just for a
product state
starting to do that we have to modify
the data set we use to probe this
Quantum process so previously we just
prepare random product State and measure
the first qubit in a z basis now what we
do is to make a very minor change we
still prepare random product State
evolve it and at the end we measure in
the random basis and we measure all the
qubits simultaneously
so one way to think about this is this
is essentially a classical Shadow
version for Quantum process and there
are previous work that explores sort of
this procedure and see what you can
actually what aspects about the quantum
process you can learn from it
essentially in previous work people
showed that you can learn the reduced
channel of this Quantum process but here
we're hopefully trying what we're hoping
to do is trying to generalize the fact
that you can learn the reduce channel to
be able to predict like arbitrary input
State I mean generally up General input
States and measure
um General more General observables
so now I want the classical data set
that we obtain is given as follows we
have some random product State given as
input these PSI L and then when we do a
random
measurement at the end we would also get
some random products today so these file
are essentially encoding what is the
basis you measure in and what's the
outcome you get so now you create this
data set if you do unrealms of them you
have PSI L mapping to file for some
random product State and in the random
product measurement outcome
so now we would like to see how to make
prediction we are given this classical
data set and we are given some State
role and we wanted to predict some
observable B
so let's say this B also has a spectrum
run between negative one and one I mean
has a spectrum one bounded by one
um so all its values between negative
one and one
so first what we're going to do is we're
going to take this observable and use it
to transform the original data set so
previously what we have is product
statement being to product State now
we're going to take this observable and
transform the output product State into
just some real value using the classical
Shadow formalism so essentially using
this form we can create this yl which is
equal to what we want in expectation
that is by doing this post-processing we
can turn the output State output to
become this real value so it's no longer
a product State and this real value has
an expectation value that's equal to
this meaning that in this new classical
data set what we have essentially done
is we have feed in this random product
State into the unknown Quantum process
and measure the observable B so just
using classical Shadow we can do this
um and furthermore
um we know that the the variance of this
yl
um it's it might be quite large but it's
always bounded by the shadow Norm of
this observable beat
so now the key thing is to understand
what this Shadow Norm actually actually
is
and essentially using this generalized
Quantum Bond and velocity inequality
again we can show that for any B that's
a sum of local observable first we can
show that the B observable the shadow
Norm of the B observable can be upper
Bound by a constant times the one Norm
of this
beta coefficient so these poly
coefficient and then using that the
generalized BH inequality we can show
that the one Norm of beta is upper
bounded by the spectral Norm of B which
then means the variance is just a
constant
so now we're essentially
back to the previous problem where we
have this classical data set telling us
that for this random product state
there's this corresponding yl value
where the yl is index station is equal
to what we want and this observable o is
the Heisenberg evolution of this
observable B
foreign
difference that is in the previous case
we only care about predicting new input
that are also product state but what we
want to do here is we wanted to predict
new inputs that are potentially say some
entangled input stereo
in order to do this we have to extend
the low weight approximation result so
previously we showed that when we
average over random product State then
we would get a Decay that's 1 over 3 to
the K and now what this Lemma
essentially says is consider any
distribution d
such that this distribution D is quite
it covers quite a bit of quantum state
in particular it covers more precisely
um the probability of sampling a state
roll would be equal to the probability
of sampling another state which is the
same state followed by some single cubic
rotation
um
are you still like really have in mind
like row is pure
um yeah actually I still have but so
like for example if it's ground state
then that's pure but you can also focus
on like thermal states that will be
mixed
so yeah I'm still thinking of it
as as it's pure
um I mean it can potentially be just a
distribution over entangles I'm just
trying to figure out what is it like the
classical analog of this locally flat
like row is just like literally one
binary string and then D is like a
distribution over binary strings with
which property
oh I don't think there's a I don't think
there's a media classical and a lot like
I think in the classical setting
um if it's just binary strings then this
D is just uniform
yeah but now there could be like this
okay okay that's what I thought yeah
okay yeah but the state but in this case
the state could have like entanglement
inside of it and then you just kind of
sprinkle some kind of local basis uh
invariance like like for example if it's
just a ground state of a generic
geometric with local hamiltonian
um then the associated distribution D
would have would have this property that
it's flat under single cubic rotation
um or it's a thermal state that would
also hold so these are just some
examples of these distribution and under
this for any of these distribution
um we would get a Decay
um for for for this lower approximation
and exponential decay but the difference
between the between this and the
previous result is that previous result
we have one over three to the K but in
this result we have one one over 1.5 to
the K and we're not entirely sure if we
can recover one over three to the K it's
seems like products data are still
indeed easier than entangle state but we
we we still get this exponential decay
so using this we can do the same thing
as before so so now the the four ml
algorithm is the following
um we would like to predict given role
try to predict the observable B the
classical data set is this product say
mapping to product state
what we would do is we would use this B
to turn the classical data set for
essentially the Heisenberg evolution of
B under this unknown process e
and then we would run this algorithm to
learn a low weight approximation to the
origin observable basically using the
Fourier transformation and then if it's
small we just set it to zero to learn it
and now after learning this low weight
approximation what we are going to do is
we're just going to predict trace of O
hat blow acting on the input State row
and we can show that this is
approximately equal to feeding in
feeding row into this unknown process
followed by measuring this observable B
so so yeah so now to
um conclude that there are some quite
surprising elements of this ml algorithm
first um it doesn't matter what this
circuit is so it could be an exponential
size circuit and even just if you try to
predict it up to some constant relative
error we only need login sample so
there's like kind of like two orders of
uh complexity involved so login samples
um but we can learn exponential size
Quantum circuit another interesting
aspect to it is that it's
computationally efficient it's
polynomial time for a constant relative
error and quantity polynomial time if
you wanted to achieve a small error
and furthermore just learning from
products to inputs the algorithm can
predict highly entangled State input
and finally the entire algorithm can be
run essentially on a classical computer
there's one part that actually requires
Quantum which is after creating this o
hat low we actually need to measure on
on the state row
um so that's the only Quantum part but
all the rest only requires classical
processing
so to conclude in this talk we're given
computationally efficient algorithm for
learning to predict the output of a
Quantum process that can potentially
have arbitrary High complexity in
particular this result shows the
potential for training ml models to
learn these kind of approximate
description so that one can predict
outcomes of a complex Dynamics much
faster than the process itself and
that's it for my talk thank you so much
for listening
great thanks thanks a lot Robert that's
very impressive
um is uh shall we take time for a few
quick questions from the audience before
we go to the panel
there's a couple in the um q a
right
um
Okay so
foreign
classical case you could consider
stochastic Matrix and look at the
average case of a product input
distributions
the age bit is independent has and has
some random bias so is that uh
uh Robert is that oh I see yeah I think
it's still slightly different from what
Ryan but I think there are a lot of
different analog one can make so of
course it's not like that's what I try
to say it's like a classical version
it's not like love classical version I
think one can definitely consider
different settings and and look at sort
of the complexity of it but I guess um
Mario
um Mary's I was always asking say if
it's still casting metrics I think that
part is not going to affect too much
because
the extreme of a stochastic metric is
still just a deterministic matrix and
that's kind of similar to in what we
study here this Quantum process can in
general be just a a unitary or even just
a classical circuit or it could also be
a still casting Matrix I think the main
part is about how we average over the
inputs um so here
um we're averaging over say pure state
but in the classical setting one one one
correspondence would say I average over
um also just B string kind of like what
I talked about but here I think Mary's
OZO was talking about a different
situation where we say it's average over
some product input distributions where
um
so it's not entirely okay so there are
two two settings so first is is the
prediction you're trying to make already
average over that is do you first do the
average and then compare the output or
you first compare the output and then
average that actually gives very
different things
um so if you already average out the the
like for example here
um say in this case
if we put the average of this row inside
this absolute value then then then you
can just set the O load to just be like
like
um essentially Alpha P Alpha I I so you
can do an even stronger kind of
approximation because in that case
you're just looking at both the average
value but here we're looking at first
doing the differencing and then average
over it and it sounded like um so what
Ryan was suggesting was something like
um you have some portion of the
averaging inside the absolute value it's
like some of the bits are actually
random and then you already average over
it but there are still some that's
outside
um of it and but it sounded like um
maybe
Mary's question was saying you you still
consider the average case so it's it's
over that input State X is the
expectation value is still outside of
the absolute value but then in this case
the the bits is independent but has
maybe some random bias I think there are
some results about that known the
classical literature where your
distribution is smooth so you're not
just looking at the uniform distribution
but you're looking at a random bias
distribution and considering the average
case prediction for that case and I
think there's also some kind of
simplification one can make but I'm not
sure if it's as strong as this kind of
exponential decay so that that would be
my my answer great there's another
question by re mitzel uh says in the
case that the observable O is just a
highway tensor product of barley
operators
yes why does the low weight
approximation work yeah that's also a
great question so I think this this
slide is really the place we should look
at to say this observable o only
contains a single bit string and that's
a highway tensor product of poly
operators
um like Sigma X on every Cubit that
that's actually going to be um
a very
that well what happens there if you do
this low weight truncation you're just
going to throw away so now this oh low
is just zero
so it feels like why why if we just put
in zero why is it going to work
um but the thing that happens here is
the following so suppose you have say
some random products today then in order
to really activate that observable it's
going to be very hard because you have
to match up the basis for all the local
product like for example if it's Sigma X
on every qubit then you have to always
pick it so that it's close to like on
the x-axis then you will activate that
observable otherwise if you're if you
have some fluctuation if you actually
select say 0 or 1 or you select y Plus
or Y minus then you're just going to get
zero there and and and that's one way to
think about it so so so it's very hard
to activate those kind of Highway string
and that's why this low weight
approximation actually works
foreign
[Music]
there's a there's a question from Bill
Huggins it seems like the requirement
that the input State be invariant under
local preferred rotations is a is a
strong one
do you have some examples of physically
interesting states with this property or
am I misunderstanding the Assumption on
the internet yeah so so I think an
example is what I wrote down here
um not sure if this is if it's
physically interesting but I have in
mind was say you have some
um generic like random like some
hamiltonian that's geometrically local
maybe in 1D but it's basis is arbitrary
and now
um essentially you consider the input
state to be say the ground state or some
low temperature thermal state of such a
hamiltonian and then you do a quench so
you kind of like you you evolve it under
some arbitrary Quantum process and you
wanted to predict what happens at the
end
um so so that's an example that I have
in mind
um I'm not I personally think it's kind
of I think it's physically interesting
um but
but I'm not sure
um whether that
yeah whatever like whether you actually
misunderstood what I said or or this
actually makes sense
um so it's not the state itself is
invariant under local Clifford
um like for example if you just have a
product State
um they're not invariant under local
rotation when you when you apply local
rotation it's going to become a
different state that's actually not why
we meant what we meant is more like just
you consider an average case over a
sufficiently broad
um class of States so so yeah so and
actually we think at least one open
question in our in our paper one of the
biggest one is we think this result
actually holds more generally for for a
much broader classes of distribution
over Quantum States and we don't yet
know if for example to what extent this
requirement is actually needed it feels
like as long as you have some
distribution that are smooth in the
quantum space space so that there are
nearby things Sarah always with similar
probability then I think this result
would hold because when you have nearby
things there with similar probability
you have this
non-orthogonality like the classical
thing that
the classical distribution is really
when it's it's really like it's com like
it's pointing to where it's very
different direction and they're all very
far apart from one another but I feel
like when you have a distribution that's
very smooth but then it seems likely
that this low degree low weight
approximation was also works
okay it's it looks like
um Ronald the world has some something
in the in the in the chat maybe Ronald
since you can do you want to just speak
up and say what's your question yeah so
there was this nice paper in the last
stock conference by um Eskenazi said
evalistically and what they did is they
gave a classical very efficient learning
algorithm for um
uh learning low degree bounded functions
on the Boolean Cube yes that's this
paper also using a version of bonoboost
Hill so I'm wondering uh like are you
sort of giving a Quantum generalization
of this results yeah I think one way you
can you can think about that but also
like in their paper they have to
explicitly say this function is a low
degree classical function but here like
I said it actually
um works for like any any any Quantum
process so you don't have it because the
first step of your argument is to go to
low degree right and afterwards maybe
this argument can take over yes so
that's that's that's uh yeah there's a
lot of parallel for example here we're
trying to prove uh Quantum analog of
this pH inequality which gives rise to
slightly different forms
um and then and then yes and then we
combine
um
yeah I think there are a lot of
parallels so you can think of it as like
a Quantum Generation
Um on this point
especially
great so it looks like Ryan has a
question but uh since you're on the
panel as well maybe we can we can just
move on to the panel and then we can
talk about it there is that okay Brian
sure okay okay great uh well thanks
thanks Robert so maybe if you stop
sharing your slides we can
and have the analysts
video pinned
so uh
so let's see let me let me introduce the
panelists uh there's Ryan O'Donnell from
CMU um who um I'm sure many of you
already know he's uh he does he's worked
extensively in complexity theory in in
the complexity of Boolean functions and
over the last so many years he's
actually started working also on Quantum
Computing on Quantum tomography Quantum
codes uh you know Quantum complexity
Theory so welcome uh Ryan
um we also have
uh Nathan B from University of Toronto
uh so Nathan of course you he's been on
uh on this colloquium before uh several
times uh he's uh he's he's done uh you
know just a lot of work on Quantum
simulation uh you know quantum chemistry
as well as Quantum methods for machine
learning so it's very appropriate to
have you on the panel and uh finally we
have Tom gurr from
um university of Berwick um uh Tom uh
works on complexity Theory Quantum
Computing as well as computational
learning theory and sublinear algorithms
so again you know very a very nice uh
set of skills for this particular talk
so um maybe
um uh you know uh I'll start with Ryan
you had something to say and you know
could you give
comments as well as your question about
the talk oh sure thanks thanks uh uh
Robert for a lot of so much cool stuff
in that talk
um yeah maybe before I get to comments I
just want to like maybe I'll ask my
technical questions just so I just make
sure I understand everything
um
I got a little bit confused because like
what is there's what is the assumption
is there on the
um the the quantum uh Channel e
oh there's no assumption right so so
then like can't like this Quantum
Channel e just like throw Row in the
trash and put out its favorite state row
yeah that you could also do that
so then it's like
exactly it would be like classical
Shadow and like shout out tomography
right
I see
uh-huh okay
thanks
um
yeah I guess like uh you know well in in
um
uh just to explain where I'm coming from
like whenever I like have like a Quantum
learning problem I'm always trying to
like just figure out like what uh you
know classical problem it's generalizing
and I usually have in the model like in
mind like okay when I see row like I'll
translate that into probability
distribution and you know if it's in
Cubase I'll translate a probability
distribution on the the Boolean strings
and if I see like uh you know the the
observable I'll translate that into like
a function mapping the Boolean strings
into let's say the interval minus one
one
and uh you know more rarely I guess
there's like a channel then like you
should map it to like I guess like a
stochastic Matrix the transforms
distributions into distributions so I
guess one thing I didn't actually uh
maybe appreciate until I saw your talk I
was just looking at the paper is that
like you're really focusing on
um
in substance pure well kind of like
focusing on pure states in the sense
that like
which kind of confused me because then
like the classical analog is like you're
learning from a probability distribution
but like you have a promise that like it
puts 100 of its mass on just like one
outcome so uh I guess I kind of had to
like
um
yeah a little bit undo that
uh that mindset
so I don't know how my sh I don't have
these panels work actually I'm afraid
I'm supposed to be in the first one
should I like keep talking or like let
them fit another family yeah sure uh you
know it's good to see you internalize
the the the the talk it's uh yeah
um
yeah I was just gonna say like I mean
one uh you know uh one tension I always
feel like with like um learning theory
because I like but I used to work on
like you know just like classical pack
learning theory like way back the day is
that like
from a theory point of view like
everything is impossible right like
Valiant events like the theory of pack
learning and you're like oh this is
going to be great we're gonna learn so
much stuff and then like there's like
zero positive results like maybe you can
learn juntas Okay and like even if
you're like oh I'm gonna severely
handicap the model by like insisting the
distribution is like the uniform
distribution which practitioners are
like no that's terrible why would you do
that but like even still like you're
like well I can maybe sort of learn
decision trees if they're sufficiently
shallow
and
it's weird though because like every
every time you start this up at the same
set up a framework like everything is
hard everything is impossible
and so it's depressing
but
um
on the other hand like now like people
are doing all sorts of cool uh learning
results so like it seems like it's
extremely hard to get like any kind of
theoretical model that like matches the
real world
and then we go to the quantum version
and I mean by definition they're like
generalizations of the classical
learning problem so by definition
they're like they can only be harder so
like man if it was like completely
impossible before it's like even
impossible or now
um so yeah I'm just trying to like think
about like this weird weird you know
this disconnect between like maybe
practice like Theory and and practice
you know you can ring out like every
possible way in which you're like well
if I take low weight linear combinations
of juntas like maybe this is also
learnable and you're like I'm really
struggling and then you know somehow in
practice it's not
as connected to the theory so okay these
are some thoughts that like occurred to
me while I was thinking about all this
Quantum learning stuff so
sorry Iran but um but you know when you
when you say it's a generalization
that's that's in the worst case right
but once you start talking about
probability distributions then it's a
whole new program so so any when you
have a when you have a uniform
Distribution on on classical inputs
that's very different from from from
this right I I disagree I think um
maybe you can
stay that classical analog
that's harder but then I would say you
stated the wrong classical analog
I mean I just always I mean I think the
correct analog is always you know turn
like a state into a probability
distribution turn observable into a
random variable turn the channel into a
stochastic transformation that's
basically your classical analog or it's
kind of like you know you know whenever
you have like power leads I X Y and Z
just delete Y and Z or just delete X and
Y and now you have like the classical
version and by definition it can only be
easier
um
well I I agree with you you know almost
all the way except when you get to a
probability distribution so so yes it's
true that that you know you you you
might say well
uh I mean in some in some cases you
might say well the analog of a pure
state is a probability distribution
because I don't know if your state is
like probably a distribution with 100 of
its mass on one no so then it's a
classical string right yeah
right and so okay at least this is okay
go ahead no so so isn't isn't that isn't
the difference that when you when you
when you have a uniform distribution
over classical strings that's different
from a uniform distribution over you
know when if you if you were taking
uniform distributions over qubits that's
a different
thing
that Robert was talking about I think
well it's a subtle thing like the best
analog of uniform distribution over
classical strings is like the maximally
mixed state like there's a thing like
there's a difference like I I'm still a
little bit confused about it like in the
classical world you can consider a thing
two things you consider
the uniform Distribution on all
probability distributions which are
Point masses
or you could consider one probability
distribution the uniform distribution
and these are definitely different
things which you know shouldn't be
confused like generally like for like
pack learning if I tell you you're
learning under the uniform Distribution
on strings
that's pretty hard like you know you can
do some stuff but it's pretty hard in
their hand if I tell you okay I'm going
to pick a random Point Mass distribution
and then you have to learn under that
your life is great you're like I need
one sample I'm pretty much done
um so
that's the distinction I see that's
that's right and and I I think it's
precisely that in the in the first case
that you mentioned the quantum classical
difference is larger
oh so like uh uh you're saying like in
the quantum case like when it's like
you have like the uniform distribution
over a pure State this is quite a lot
harder than the uniform distribution
over a point Mass
or different tips yes
um it should only be harder right like
in the first time
literally two to the end possibilities
in the quantum case you know there's
like a Continuum possibilities
um I thought the result was at least
that it seems like it's easier right so
yeah and in fact in fact you know okay
so you're into I mean the intuitively
you should say well it would be easier
because because now now your typical
state
is um you know there's there's a lot
more overlap you you have you have a
chance that that your output has you
know is um is um is much more you know
there are fewer possibilities you know
that's the low degree polynomial right
it's uh it's much more random you have
but just because uh you know uh it's not
just that you pick pick that random uh
an input which was a classical input and
these are all very different now you
picked at random Quantum State and these
these have much more overlap
uh I
well I still don't buy it I mean I'm I'm
going to like keep going and pressing on
you if you like but I don't want to
totally derail it I still don't buy it
to be honest we should move on we could
come back
and Nathan you had something to say yeah
I just wanted to say that you know from
my point of view I figuring out the
classical analog of a Quantum learning
problem I I don't think is unique
uh because there's multiple ways that
you can think about a representation of
quantum and classical data like you know
for example a feature Vector that you're
considering for a particular learning
problem could be embedded in a quantum
computer literally as a bit string or it
could be embedded as a pure State wave
function
you know there's different there's
different uh benefits and different
issues behind all of those uh sort of uh
embeddings of the quantum information or
classical analogs of the quantum problem
um and so I or I should say I guess
Quantum analogs of the classical problem
in this case and so because this mapping
isn't necessarily like prescriptive I
don't know I take a I take a less uh uh
clear I've got a less Clear View than
Ryan does about this about how we should
always think about a classical analog of
a Quantum problem or vice versa I think
that you know you just we just have to
be careful that when we do do the
comparison that we're thinking about an
appropriate analogy uh between it and
we're clear about it
foreign
this kind of makes me think about Samir
who's mentioned earlier during the talk
um which is there are many ways in which
this will have classical analogs and and
in some sense the the main reason the
main power
um of the result comes from this
smoothness
um of the inputs versus the sharp uh
phenomena In classical case and I wonder
whether the you know this dramatic gap
of exponential versus something which is
um you know um polynomial or quality
polynomial whether there is a natural
classic a classical analog of the
question for which this is also
um possible and efficiently doable
I think that would be also quite
interesting
yeah
so so so I guess uh was wasn't that
question uh if you if you uh you know so
so as Ryan was saying that these two
different Notions that you know you
could say well you have the uniform
distribution as input or your you know
your your you have a uniform
distribution over over classical inputs
right so you're thinking of drawing a
input at random so now if instead you
drew an input at random but but now not
from not from one of the end bit strings
but you drew a input distribution at
random which was a which was sort of a
product distribution
and now you you're asked the same
question classically when wouldn't you
get low complexity again
yes I think one way to at least going
back to the random products they result
we can say suppose we have this random
products data was being sampled and now
we just smash it onto the the z-axis so
now we have this black sphere you just
smash it onto z-axis now that would just
be like um probability distribution in
in there and and in that case I mean
everything that I said about the quantum
settings
like this low degree approximation and
so on would also go through into this
model so I think that is that that's the
place where you can
make it into the the setting where it
makes kind of
um like the analogy becomes much more
similar and actually the classical one
is just a special case of of the quantum
result that I just talked about so I
think that's indeed true but but then in
that case you're generating a
distribution over
classical bit strings but in the
original Quantum case it's still a pure
state so I guess now you you're you're
you're breaking essentially whether you
think a pure State should be mapped into
like a distribution with a single point
Mass on a classical bit string for
example so
so if you try to do that analogy then it
would break this other analogy but I
think if you do this analogy then things
becomes closer but if you do the analogy
of pure State it's more like bit strings
than than the the thing becomes weird so
at least that's my understanding of the
of the situation so Robert here's a
little bit of an uh annoying question
I'm sure you've gotten you've gotten you
have been forced to answer on a number
of occasions but I'm kind of curious
about the Choi John Makowski isomorphism
when it comes to this so you know under
what circumstances could you view the
channel learning problem as a particular
instance of the state learning problem
yeah that's a great that's a great
question like um actually that's also an
a relation that people use in some of
the prior work on classical shadow of
quantum channels so in those Works what
they essentially do is say suppose you
have unknown Channel take the choice
state which is like feeding in Bell pair
and then get the state and now do
classical Shadow on this Choice tip and
now you can of course you can get you
can just Port all the results here
um but but then
a lot of the things you actually wanted
actually doesn't hold anymore like for
example if you wanted to be able to like
feed in row into this
Channel and then predict an observable
when you use the childrenkowski
representation what you get is actually
it would be some observable
um apply onto the choice state but like
there's equality you can write down but
actually that observable will have an
exponential
um spectral Norm because in Choice State
you divide everything by an exponentiary
like two to the end so now you have to
circum like you have to kind of mitigate
that so now the observable becomes like
this crazy observable and classical
Shadow cannot predict those kind of
things so so that yeah that causes the
connection to break down
and so I guess another thing that I've
always wondered about with uh with this
stuff and I was wondering if you've got
any any feedback on on this is that I've
always kind of wondered about you know
um memory in uh the the channels in
particular you know let's look at
something that'd be really simple like a
time-dependent hamiltonian
do you have any idea about how you would
end up you know say learning a
parameterized family of uh say time
dependent Quantum channels using these
types of techniques
oh
yeah that's like so I guess what you
mean is you have some Channel with
additional parameter time and now you
want exactly you're able to learn all of
them right so so in this setting um at
least in the setting that I just talked
about what one I have to do is the
following so one way to do it is like
you pick some random time and for each
time you do what I just talked about so
now you kind of get an approximate model
of this e and now what you have to do is
you have to perform interpolation or
perhaps some kind of extrapolation
between different time right in order to
cover how it's transitioning and so on
so perhaps maybe if it's smoothly
smoothly deviating or has some kind of
pattern inside it then you can also
learn learn that
time dependent kind of channels for it
so
with that is that what you have in mind
or you're thinking more no I was just
kind of curious about you know
um yeah I was kind of curious about that
and also you know uh one of the
challenges that of course ends up coming
up with some other techniques is that
you know for the time depending case
likelihood evaluation for short time
Evolutions becomes uh
no longer possible to evaluate the
probabilities that you'd end up seeing
because you need you know by necessity
to go to a long time Evolution so many
of the ideas behind classical shadows
and things like that end up starting to
break down as you start needing to do
longer and longer revolutions to end up
seeing the long time behavior of your
Channel
so you know that was one of the things
that I've run into when I've tried to
when I thought about trying to do this
in the past so I was just kind of
curious about your Notions of how it
might be done
oh I see I see I see
but I suppose inside your your formalism
it might not be so bad as the way that I
I'd originally thought about it right I
think it because like it depends on how
how big it's fluctuating like maybe it's
like some periodic thing then you just
learn the time Dynamics for For Those
portions maybe using this procedure that
I just talked about so you have to chunk
up for a different time learn it and now
you can kind of like understand what it
looks like and now you you just keep
applying the same thing
um for if it's periodic but if it's
actually changing all the way then then
one would just have to go to higher and
higher time in order to learn what that
actually is at least that side I think
that's that should be the situation
so I guess another thing I'm kind of
curious about is uh Quantum um you could
I guess you could use your result in
order to do something analogous to gate
set tomography couldn't you that's true
I think uh that should be possible right
and so then if you end up getting the uh
getting something like that is there
some notion of gauge then that would end
up coming in in this uh yeah in this
concept in this concept yeah that's a
great question
um so in this setting we're assuming you
can control what you feed in and what
you measure so in that case that you you
you you fix all the gauge so there's no
gauge Freedom you can actually learn
what the system is if you go to like
very large number of measurements and
experiments
um but then you can also say maybe we
don't know what the state is maybe we
don't know what the measurements we're
doing we don't know what this e is and
when we were trying to learn everything
yeah in that case I think gauge gauge
problem could potentially come in but I
think sometimes you can avoid it like
for example if the evolution itself is
like unitary then there's ways you can
fix the gauge and and so on so
I'm a bit curious about um something
else so
you're making no assumptions whatsoever
on the quantum process right it could be
anything
right so suppose you do make some
assumptions suppose you're saying maybe
that's um
highly structured maybe it's polynomial
time
um generated can can you get something
better this way
yeah that's a I think it's also a very
very good question
um I I also thought about it so like one
thing that I that I thought about was um
suppose this is more like just Italian
dependent hamiltonian so so suppose this
is just uh say e to the iht where each
etch is like an interacting hamiltonian
maybe a local hamiltonian on incubits
then can we do better
um then what we just talked about the
answer is yes so in that case you can
learn the channel
like up to time and distance for example
So like
um when when you say it's generated by
low climatonian and you can probe
different time then then there are
procedure that you can learn it very
efficiently
um for example in this paper in this
work the scaling with respect to the
error is quite bad it's like quasi
polynomial in one over Epsilon but for
learning many body hamiltonian from
Dynamics you can prove that you can
learn it with just one of our Epsilon
essentially
so it's like a kaisenberg type limit so
which is like yeah
and yeah but but if you just assume it's
a polynomial time Quantum circuit
actually I don't know I don't I suspect
so here's my suspicion like if it's
possible to create something like a
pseudo-random unitary then in that case
you can hide information about costs
like this kind of polynomial time
Quantum circuit and make it kind of
computationally indistinguishable from
from from exponential complexity type of
quantums circuit then in that case I
think the hardness would kind of
be the same like you will not get too
much improvement but I think people
haven't constructed yet yet so this kind
of intuition that I had is not rigorous
um in any way
you know there's there's something
um not not quite along these lines but
it's it's reminiscent you know so
um uh you know uh this this is in the in
the context of random circuit sampling
you know there's this book of GAO and
Juan
um where where they should again you
know in the same you using this
um this you know this party
decomposition that
um that you can
you can you can sample only the low
weight poly polies and and get a quasi
polynomial enter the login classical
algorithm for for reconstructing the
output distribution so
um you know it's it's not it's not the
it's not the same kind of learning
problem where you're you know now the
now the random thing is the circuit the
input is sort of fixed and the output is
in the standard basis but but uh but
there seems to be some maybe it's a
duality or there's some some way of this
these may be related
yeah I've actually read that paper
um so so yes indeed like the low degree
approximation part is very similar but I
if I remember correctly I think in their
paper the low degree part actually comes
from the noise in the system right like
for example like when you apply Gates
there's actually
um a noise that causes no degree to
happen and actually I think there is a
relation okay so using that intuition
one can also get a result here is
suppose you have some distribution
um that such that it's an arbitrary
distribution and now let's say you apply
single qubit depolarizing channel on
your state so now when you sample a
state you want to predict you don't just
want it to predict that state but you
you wanted to predict um when you have
some noise in it what's the outcome I
think in that case one might potentially
also have these kind of uh low degree
approximation to hold and I think in
that case it will be
at least sort of
technique technically probably also much
closer to what they were they were doing
um but in this case
um the the state is can actually be pure
but it's kind of like because of the
randomness and the randomization of the
initial state it causes the collapse
um
so I'm not sure maybe there are also
some relation
um of that effect that's been that could
be
that could be connected back but yeah I
haven't haven't seen how it's it's it's
it's uh it's connected yet
so so something else that would be kind
of you know I think an interesting
question is you know let's assume what
you had is you had a arbitrary
differential equation
that you wanted so let's say a linear
differential equation and um you are
given access to the Dynamics through a
block encoding
of it I'm kind of curious you know what
uh to what extent the the types of
results that have been you know
developed so far like your own who would
be usable in order to be able to
identify the differential equation
that's being block encoded in the larger
unitary
because one of the problems with the
block encoding is you often are going to
need a relatively High poly weight term
in order to be able to specify the
particular block that you're interested
in so do you know of any way that you
could get the the the notion of Channel
learning and you know and block
encodings to play nicely together
but I see
so my intuition is usually when you get
access to block encoding it's a stronger
form of access so then you can kind of
like
um
thanks is it more is that the right
intuition that I should have well I
shouldn't think deeply about the block
encoding part but okay because I mean
you could view it as an Iraq as an
oracle right and every time that you're
looking at your channel learning problem
you can view that as an oracle
identification problem where you've got
a Oracle that ends up implementing a
single invocation of your channel and
what you'd like to be able to do is
you'd like to be able to come up with a
model or a specification of what that
Oracle is and the same thing ends up
happening with you know something like a
block encoding of a differential
equation
where you know you've got an oracle that
ends up describing the larger unitary
and you'd like to be able to
parameterize that by its action only on
a sub block of the of the Hilbert space
that it acts on and that that behavior
inside that subblock need not be unitary
and that's one of the key things in
order to be able to implement it on the
you know non-unitary Dynamics like you
would see and say you know some
dissipative differential equation
and so you know it would be really cool
to be able to use these results to be
able to say hey I don't have to just
learn Dynamics inside the quantum
formalism I could actually
um you know kind of pack the quantum
pack learnish uh you know arbitrary
dynamical systems but in order to be
able to do that you need to find a way
to be able to get these ideas to play
well with the block encoding so that way
you can fit those problems inside the
quantum formalism easily so I was just
wondering if you thought about it but
you know the answer is that might still
be an open question to see how far we
can push uh these sorts of ideas in that
in that direction
right so in those kind of settings
you're you're you have this differential
equation that you try to learn is that
is that what you're as an example yeah
you could consider you know like some
some differential equation that's be a
the solution is being uh block encoded
by you know say a solution say the um
differential equation solver which uh
that bury it all did ages ago which
involves like a matrix inverse of the uh
the uh of the differential operator that
they're carrying out so the block uh the
way it works is a this is a unitary
operation
sub block of that larger unitary
operation is the solution to the
differential equation in essence and
what you'd like to be able to do is
you'd like to be able to build a model
for the solution to the differential
equation given access to the larger
unitary as your Channel
but you don't care about the channel as
a whole you only end up caring about
this one block of uh of the the process
Matrix
I guess in that case you probably wanted
to consider us a different input
distribution because
in order to access that specific block
and so on so at least it feels like
that's kind of what I was thinking too
yeah
yeah I think one way to go forward is to
First better understand sort of how well
does these kind of Channel learning
results apply to different set of
distributions So currently we show that
when distribution is satisfy this
constraint then we can do this but
perhaps it holds for even more
distribution and then that might uh
eventually give rise to what you were
suggesting perhaps um but along similar
lines it's also interesting that almost
all the work inside the Space is really
strongly wedded to poly representations
um
so you know there there are some
physically relevant settings like for
example if you're dealing with a bosonic
system
where it's very difficult to be able to
represent the natural operators as a
polynomially sized uh linear combination
of poly operators so there may actually
also be other other examples of
representations of channels that may
still be efficient to learn but might
not be efficient inside the you know
framework of low intersection
hamiltonians and the like that have been
studied so far I see I see
[Music]
yeah so
um
well really impressive work Robert so
can I ask you a question you know just
to clarify so you you did motivate all
this in the in the beginning of your
talk you you sort of said in what what
setting this might be useful but that
was uh you know that was before we got
to the the actual results and understood
the setting so at least for me and maybe
for others it might be helpful if you
were to now that we've seen all this if
you were to go back and say you know how
do you think this would be useful or you
know can you can you make up a setting
where
where this would this would actually be
uh you could see being
yeah that's actually a um a very nice
question I did indeed I didn't
didn't go back and talk about sort of
implications
um it was part of it was discussed in
the paper but but it's nice that you
brought it up I should sort of say a few
words about what I think
um so for example like in the first
example that I sat was say that you
wanted to learn a model so that now
given some specification for initial
State You can predict what would happen
under some complex physical process and
predict what would happen at the end
um so
so one specific example would be I think
I briefly mentioned it was like you have
some ground state or low energy thermal
states of your of some generic
hamiltonian that's like local generic
low quantitonian and that now you have
this as initial State and you wanted to
say do uh Evolution under it so maybe
you change the hamiltonian certainly you
apply some magnetic field you do some
things with it and now it will evolve
and then generate some output State and
maybe you wanted to measure some kind of
uh some like thermodynamic quantity of
it and I think that would potentially be
an example that fits into it the only
problem is do people really care about
ground states of some generic low
carbontonian maybe they only care about
very specific translationally variant
hamiltonian and so on so that part is
still a little bit unclear um but at
least this specific example that I said
it would work like all the theorem would
go through and and we can indeed make a
prediction of that so that's the first
example the second example I talked
about is in Quantum machine learning so
you have a quality Network and so for
example one people one thing that people
do is they take a classical vector and
they map it into what people call QB
rotation so it's like you the the
there's like un-dimensional vector now
you map into encubus system where each
qubit it's just like rotating
um by an end goal based on the real
value of the system and now you will try
to train the parameterized quantum
circuit some
deep one or a shallow one and then
measure something at the end and usually
what people hope is that this class of
function taking you you from X into the
output is going to be in general hard to
hard to simulate classically because
it's a Quantum circuit so hopefully it
will have more expressive power than
constical ml algorithm one thing what
this result says is suppose your input
is just some say 0 to 2 pi and then it's
like uniform the random in that space
and now you do cubic rotation to map in
to say just like like say on this on the
slice of black sphere
um one can prove that no matter how deep
your Quantum neural network is even as
an exponentially deep that whole thing
can be computed that whole thing can be
computed by some classical
model dots only take quasi polynomial
time so it means there's a collapse in
it so even if your Quantum circuit is
explanation deep it can be simulated by
the quality polynomial thing but it's
not a usual form of stimulation because
given the circuit you actually cannot
write like write down what that
classical model is
um but what it what the result says is
it's not more expressive so if you have
the another class and you use this like
you compare these two class to learn
some other function using quantity
network will not be like in this
particular form would not be more
powerful so that would be one
application in sort of a more negative
light and then the third example that I
talked about was like can you speed up
complex Quantum Dynamics and I think
this results as you can indeed Do It
um at least from exponential to Quality
polynomial but it's not entirely clear
if you just have a polynomial thing can
you even compress it further so that
that that Still Remains to be understood
further so
I think I finally got like a classical
analog that I kind of understand
can I run it by you
yeah I was I mean I was a little sort of
mystified by the fact that like okay
there's literally any Quantum Channel at
all in the middle
so I guess the way you sort of handle is
you you know do the transpose and stick
it onto the observable so now you're
like okay well now it's a little
worrisome because I have literally
anything observable at all
uh if you have literally any observable
and you don't have much assumptions
about your input distribution or state
this is going to be not so good so it
must be that like you have to
um
kind of change your like figure of Merit
of like how well you're going to
evaluate like how well you did learning
on this distribution or Distribution on
distributions I guess you need a
distribution on distributions to measure
things
and I guess like still like it can't
just be like oh like it can be any
state or any distribution because that's
a worst case thing so it's kind of like
you you have this assumption that like
well if I if I draw from the
distribution I want like distributions
on states where like first I draw from
the state and then I don't mind if you
like stick extra noise on top of that
state
like that's still the distribution and
then I'm going to average over this
so
maybe the right classical analog is like
okay you can have any
um
you're trying to learn like that
averaging is only done outside right
like you're comparing different circuit
and then you need to make good
prediction or all the circuits been
pushed into the observable though so
like there's no circuit anymore you're
just uh you're getting a randomly chosen
distribution and you have to
learn
on average over the choice of this
randomly chosen distribution or state
right
and like it's always like there's
there's a there's a single distribution
over Quantum State
um
and you have to learn well under that
distribution right so
uh yeah that's right say random products
but like the fact that it's like locally
flat is kind of similar to saying like
you take this distribution Over States
and you have to not mind if like you
take those States but then like put some
additional like noise on them in a
certain sense so one way I think about
it is like fun so you take arbitrary
distribution of states and now you
create a new distribution which the new
distribution is generally as files you
first sample from that distribution row
and now you apply say uh depth one
random circuit yeah yeah exactly exactly
good and like you have a very tough task
because you're learning like literally a
completely arbitrary observable yes
um yes I think maybe the right like
classical and like thing that like it
feels like a satisfying classical analog
to me is like okay you're learning a
completely arbitrary function on the
Boolean Cube into
I don't know if it's bounded or not but
anyway I completely maybe uh it should
be bounded okay about it
um and then you're gonna be kind of
getting like a randomly chosen
distribution to learn about and I was
like oh this is very bad because like
you have a randomly chosen Point
distribution
but not really like like you said like
you first somebody randomly choose the
point distribution but then that
distribution is like further noise
and so like I think like well you're not
really like you just apply another
circuit so it really it's gonna lock you
apply a classical Boolean circuit then
that's still a point distribution it's
not yeah so I think like the right model
is maybe like you take the distribution
and you make a new distribution where
like you
star out or question mark out or erase
like a random subset of the bits and
then you measure how well you're doing
with respect to this kind of like
uniform on a sub Cube It's like a
mixture of Uniforms on sub cubes kind of
distributions
um
and this is kind of good because like if
you're like oh if the distribution if
the thing I'm trying to learn is parity
like how can I possibly learn it like
for every different point distribution
like I have a different parity plus or
minus one never gonna learn it but like
the lucky thing is like once you take
your even your point distribution and
you put this extra basically you pass it
through an Erasure Channel like once you
pass this point distribution through an
Erasure Channel parity basically becomes
the zero function so
um
you have a hope to learn it right
right so in some sense like this extra
maybe a racer channel is like okay I
think I get it now yeah I think this
radio channel wow it's like mixed
Channel but in the quantum case you can
make it pure but something like that yes
yeah like like pure Channel pure random
circuit is kind of like erase your
channel yeah this is like kind of like
maybe what like Nathan was saying like
every analogy is like a little bit
imperfect but like all right you break
something I feel I now feel like
satisfied with this analogy where like
the story is you're learning kind of
under a worst case distribution but like
your friend helps you out a little bit
by saying like well actually you know
take the worst case distribution and
like pass it through a racer Channel and
now you're like oh thank God like now uh
like the high frequencies are not going
to bother me anymore and so now it's
much more like I'm like a low degree
like every observable is like a low
degree observable
okay cool
I'm glad I'm gonna got on the right
track thank you
great
well um
I missed this there's some something
else uh another comment I think one yeah
one thing actually I'd like to to get
out of you uh Robert is I'm kind of
curious what do you think are the the
next Frontiers in this space because
after all you know the uh the the
frontier and hamiltonian learning as
well as you know this uh uh well your
new channel learning result has been
really rapidly expanding so you know if
you were to kind of make a call to arms
for people to think about some problems
uh in this space what what would you
recommend people start thinking about
yeah that's also a great question
um let me think a little bit
so personally I am interested in a
following question which I think might
be too ambitious because there is no
classical analog of it but not not like
I mean the classical analog of it hasn't
been developed yet but I was wondering
like what kind of quantum algorithm can
we actually learn like if you're just
given some examples and now we're being
asked to to to design a Quantum
algorithm for solving those examples and
it has to generalize to bigger system
size and so on is there even hope that
we can say something
um about the ability to learn Quantum
algorithm and and so on I think that's a
challenging question and I don't really
know how to really address that question
so I would say that that would be
something like classically you can also
say ask the same thing how do you design
classical algorithm I don't think
there's like Ryan said everything is not
learnable that it's just not addition
and I don't know how one can do do it
but it seems like even
um like empirically people have been
doing a lot of interesting things that
are approaching that point I mean
they're not really designing super good
algorithm I mean there's this the swap
test algorithm was pretty interesting oh
that's true that's true you mean the
quantum the variational one where they
find the belt yeah yeah that's indeed
true yeah like but that's more like
heuristic like if you just try and then
they saw that it seems to be able to
find something good exactly good point
very different than being able to
rigorously approve something like you
can't impact context yeah so that would
be one thing that I'm personally very
interested in another thing that was
actually being often asked by by
physicists is they they tell me that oh
I what I really want the machine
learning algorithm to do is not just to
like do some benchmarking and predict
some property but I wanted to learn new
physics and I was like I have no idea
how one could do that
um so like
is it possible to have algorithm that
can actually learn kind of new things in
Quantum systems and what does it mean to
be new I don't know like it that would
be very
the people are trying in a more
empirical way
um and I think it'll be interesting if
there are some rigorous ground that we
can make of course that would be hard I
feel like that's still that's very
challenging but I I would really hope
that
like learning theory can develop to a
point that we can say something
interesting about these kind of very
more high-level questions and and on a
more technical note I think and Ryan
should also comment on it I think even
just the original shout tomography
there's still this big open question
which I don't know the answer to
which is so
so in in the original shelter Market
task is you have a Quantum State role
and now you can have multiple copy of
the state and now you wanted to be able
to estimate a large number of property
um and and Scott arenson has some
results saying that if you wanted to do
it in the following way that is you have
all these copies you want it to have a
Quantum circuit that turn it into some
small classical description like
polynomial size classical description
such that by using that classical
description You can predict a large
number of property you will collapse
certain things basically Quant advice
would be equal to classical device or
it's not likely that's true I think the
following more
simpler setting might still be true
which is suppose you have these multiple
copies of your state that you can store
in your Quantum memory you never turn it
into a classical description but you
just store it and now you can every time
every time people someone would come by
and say hey I care about this observable
it's it's easy to write down this is
here is the circuit
um
and you can perform some Quantum
computation on top of it can you
actually do it computationally
efficiently while only using like poly
log M amount of copies of the state and
I think that's not clear like I at least
I don't know if there's a
there's a there's a computational
hardness for it or whether we can
actually create a computationally
efficient algorithm for it Brian have
you thought about this so I didn't quite
miss the setup is it not it's not just
adaptive uh Shadow tomography is it is
that what you mean or no I think it's
just yeah it's just adaptive like you
can keep a Quantum memory so you never
really turn it into just classical
description that you just did and now
people come you do some measurements
um I think it's kind of almost there
right like you think you're looking for
threshold I think it's good right but
yeah I think even like one of the
earlier papers by Aronson achieves
adaptive version doesn't it I don't
think so the online learning of quantum
state is bad
uh computationally very hard oh you're
interested in the computational
efficiency yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
don't know I have to think about that
yeah I don't know so at least I I feel
like like having that would be very
useful because then in the future you
can just store some number of quantum
data and now whatever things come you
can predict kind of similar to this case
for example if this works then you can
bootstrap what I just talked about for
channel learning to predicting more
observable like here we focus on
observables that are essentially just
like local observables but now if what
we just talked about here uh like what I
just said works then you can just
boosted into like predicting any
observable um like any efficiently
measurable observable
um I think they have these things like
same dilemmas though even in the
classical adaptive data analysis case
though where like they have like much
worse guarantees if you have to be
computationally efficient
uh
uh
um
no you can't tolerate like poly log m in
that case this is like you can only get
like square root M or whatever if I'm
not mistaken which I might be mistaken
but uh we should check into like whether
you can like anybody's managed to do it
even in the classical case the classic
okay shout out to Mario if you did what
I just said you can do it right
um like suppose this density metrics row
is diagonal then then this can be done
efficiently
adaptively
well I'll check my maybe I don't I'll
catch with you later because maybe I
don't either exactly remember my sources
or we're maybe talking about slightly
different problems
sounds good yeah but yeah that's another
from a more technical side I think
that's at least to me it's big open
passion I thought about it quite for for
a very long time but I still don't know
um how to solve it thank you okay great
uh well you know this was really a
fantastic talk and great discussion
afterwards so so thanks Robert and
thanks
thanks Nathan and
Tom and
Ryan
um
thanks so much Robert yeah thank you so
much
it was very fun thank you
bye